[Music]
today we are here with Taylor from
quantify who is the practice lead for
public sector and higher education we're
very excited to explore some of the
solutions built but quantify before we
dig in Taylor can you tell us a little
bit about quantified yeah of course
we've been around six years now we focus
primarily on
AI and machine learning solutions we
found that we're able to provide a lot
of value for customers by helping them
with their data strategy as well because
you know that's kind of one of the
fundamental building blocks of any AI or
ML initiative we have been a Google
cloud partner since 2016 obviously with
that AI machine learning background
we've been very close with Google cloud
and have 325 GCP certified professionals
which is about a quarter of our
workforce we've actually been the 2017
and 2018 machine learning partner of the
year and are a contact center AI launch
partner as well that's awesome Congrats
on the ml partner of the year and for
being a CCAI launch partner can you tell
us a bit more about CCAI and what it
means to be a launch partner yes so
there's three components to CCAI
there's a topic modeler which uses
keyword clustering to identify high
frequency topics there's dialogue flow
which is the NLP back and kind of the
virtual agents so to speak and then if
there is an instance where it needs to
be transferred to a live agent
there's functionality called agent
assist that uses a real-time keyword
search from the conversation between the
live agent and the customer to pull up
suggestions from the knowledge base and
help them answer questions quickly as a
launch partner we help customers through
the entire lifecycle of a deployment so
that's everything from helping them
design conversation flows programming
intents building integrations with the
knowledge base CRM systems anywhere else
that you know user data might exist and
then also you know building that agent
a6 functionality as well great thanks
for sharing more about that can you talk
more in depth about the types of
technologies that quantify uses yes so
because we've been using dialogue flow
since before it was even actually called
dialogue flow we've built a lot of
custom machine learning models that
you build manage and deploy any of these
dialog floor contact center AI solutions
one of them is intent identification so
that takes your historical call or chat
logs understands the ways that users are
asking questions and programs that
context directly into the virtual agent
another involves the ingestion of text
so think a you know knowledge base or
FAQ section on your webpage it pulls out
questions and answer pairs there and
again makes it directly programmable
into the virtual agent we also work a
lot with the NLP sentiment analysis that
exists in dialogue flow take it a step
further in what we call a motion
analysis so trying to understand when
users are having these negative feelings
identifying that earlier and helping you
intervene before it starts becoming too
negative and of an impact on customer
satisfaction lastly we deal a lot with
integrations so having your users or
constituents reach out to you on
whatever platform they feel comfortable
is very important to creating value for
the people that will be interacting with
the solution whether that be voice chat
messenger platforms SMS dialogue flow
has all those integrations built in and
very easily accessible can you talk
about some of the specific solutions
that quantify has built with CCI
yeah so when a lot of people here
contact center AI they think of the
traditional call center while it's a
great tool for that we found that the
NLP capabilities behind dialogue flow
are actually useful in a lot of other
situations as well there was some work
that we did in conjunction with Google
Cloud and Penn State World Campus where
we used the NLP capabilities of dialogue
flow they had identified four different
types of student requests where advisors
were spending up to five thousand hours
per year really just pulling different
pieces of information during determining
a student's eligibility to change major
campus something like that so we use
dialogue flow to recognize the intents
of those users provide a templated
response to the advisor that can then be
personalized based on the student all
while pulling all of that data that they
had to spend 15 minutes gathering
putting it right in front of them
and giving them the opportunity to add
value with their time rather than just
searching for data what are some of the
challenges that you've encountered when
building these solutions yes so the
first one that comes to mind is
designing conversation flows not always
do customers understand what they want
to automate and how they want the agent
to say it so we found that with using
the topic modeler you can not only find
a lot of the high frequency topics but
you can dig down a level understand
within those topics what people are
talking about and help structure the
conversation flow of the virtual agent
using that we've also seen intent
clashing a lot so as you continue to add
intents to the bot it becomes more and
more likely that there's going to be
similarities between an existing intent
so we've created an automated solution
testing tool that goes through and tests
those intense every so often and gives
you an early indication if there's going
to be problems with previous intent so
that you can intervene and fix that
before it ever sees the light of day
well this has been very interesting
thank you so much for being here with us
today it was my pleasure if you'd like
to learn more about quantify you can
visit quantify calm thanks for watching
and stay tuned for more episodes of
stock chat
[Music]
you